Okay, we're all set. Right, well this is the final detail design meeting. We're going to discuss the look and fill design, the easier interface design, and we're going to evaluate the product. And the end result of this meeting has to be a decision on the details of the remote control, like, absolute final decision. And then I'm going to have to specify the final design in the final report. So just from last time to recap, we're going to have a snooman shaped remote control with no LCD display, no need for torque back. It was hopefully going to be kinetic power and battery with rubber buttons, maybe backlighting the buttons with some internal LEDs to shine through the casing, hopefully a job dial, and incorporating the slogan somewhere as well. Anything I missed? Okay, Sue, if you
want to present your approach to your type, go ahead. That's it, Ninja Homo made in Japan. There are future instances of me, where I'm looking at the expense sheet, and it's going to be quite a lot expensive to have open up now what's the buttons and stuff inside. So instead of this is going to be an LCD screen, just have a very basic one, very small, with access to the menu through the scroll wheel and confirm and button. Okay, I'll recognize this is pretty much the same for the last time. It doesn't open up to
the advanced functions, so the advanced functions are still hidden from you, but they're hidden in this internet, they're not in use. Where are they? They're in the LCD panel in the jogdow. So what kind of thing is going to be? The LCD panel just displays functionally what you're doing, using an advanced function, brightness, contrast, whatever. It would just say, it only has four columns, it's a very simple LCD, or as many the minimum amount that the usual automatically know, this is brightness or this is contrast. It might even be one a bit more complex LCD panel, with pictures like maybe the sun, or the symbols of the virus. And what is this here? That's a number pad. Okay, so the number pad is... Where are we going to have this slogan? I'm just like... Along the side. Yeah. Okay, cool. You have this space here, and then you have this thing on the side as well. Or at the bottom. The slogans are usually quite small, right? They're not like huge, so... There's... Say a button about this size, right? So you would still have plenty of space for a slogan? So if this isn't
to scale, what kind of dimensions are you thinking about here? Well, one... The button is to be big enough
to pick easily with a finger. So we're reckon... Maybe that'll be about the same size as the pamiarant. Yeah,
so that would be about a centimeter for a button. So one, two, three... Four centimeters... Plus maybe half... Five...
Seven... Yeah, nine... That sounds bad. Ten centimeters. That would be good. So ten centimeters in height. Okay. That would
be good. In fact, a pen is about ten centimeters usually. So that would be... That sounds like a really
good sign. Yeah. You see it there? That's great, and it's very bright as well. So... Okay, is it possible...
You're just going to bring the idea of colors. Are these the colors that have production? Is this just what
we had available? We're going to have again the foggy yellow and last name that's up when you... Okay, so
this could do list all the things that it does. So I can add them on the report. It's fun.
Because it's red, it's very problem. We're going to use it as... It's going to be the power button if you hold it for maybe two seconds. I'll send it on by signal. Apart from that, it's going to be used as a confirm button for the LCD screen. Okay. And to use this as a joke, though. Okay. So
that's like an okay, though. Oh, we've discussed how high it is, but how wide is it? Okay. How high is it? No, as in the height. Yeah. But what about the width? Oh, like depth of the actual height. Yeah, we need five. We're about three and a half. Okay. Oh, is this to get an idea of scale
from your... Sure. ...sharing thing there. Okay. So you can par on and off. What else can you do? You
can skip straight to the channel using these buttons. Okay. We're open to have the volume control here. But because we've got the LCD in the jogdalf, we just start with the whose that is the volume. Okay, jogdalf is volume. And what else do you do with the jogdalf? You can use it for more advanced functions like contrast
color. Contrast, brightness. And then it's nice. It's whatever else. What it's to include is the advanced functions. And then I still go through it's best by the... What are the designers, what are they? What can I TV do?
Okay, things like brightness contrast. Uh -huh. Maybe tuning the channels. Okay, channel -talking - What else, the various inputs? So you have a VCR having, you know, which input do you have? Okay. From the color sharpness. Yeah, color sharpness. So a lot of these things will have to be free and open for users to define them. Okay,
what about sign settings? Or can you change any of those at all? Audio. We have like your basic, your
base, your mid -range, your high -range. You have the bounce. Yep. Left -right -downs. Maybe even pre -programmed sound modes. Okay. The user could determine like a series of sound modes. And then what could happen would be when
you click on that and go to that same. Okay. Is there anything else I can do? Because that's fine, you just need to know so I can write it down. Okay. Right? I guess that's it. So we can now have a little look at the Excel sheet and price this thing and see if we need to. If we need to rethink anything at all. So for this first part here, par wise, have we battery? Battery. Do we have kinetic as well? No. No. Okay. Just battery. We need a battery. Not because of cold stress, is it? Okay. What about the electronics here? The bounce chip? We need a non -strip, I think. Yes. Let me just confirm that. Okay. What does it mean by single and double, do you know? I think single is a
piece of one, our global, where it doubles this sort of thing. So we want double cars? Yeah. Okay. Plastic.
Is there any rubber at all in the buttons? I think we're going to have to skip the rubber. Okay. And we want to special colors, don't we? So I'll have to pop that. Oh no wait, how many colors
have we got there? For the case itself, one color. It's one special color. It's just one color, okay? Because
the case unit itself, the rest of it, it's a little bit too much. So interface -wise, is it this third option we have? Yes. The two of them there. One. The LC this way. Okay. And then buttons. I
mean. We have two colors. We've got push buttons as well. Like, oh wait, so push button and integrate the
school. Okay. We've got one button for this thing, because it's just one big sheet of rubber. Uh -huh. And not sure if it's correct. Okay. Let's just be safe and put, like say, four buttons for that one. Okay.
Okay. And maybe a special color for the months, or maybe four again. Four? So, why are we arriving at the number four? What is the number four come from? Because that's one button, but it's the complexity of 12
buttons. Okay. Right? So we're only just estimating that, yeah. We'll be less. Okay. But these, are we wanting them and - No. No. They're just - Is everything going to be plastic? Okay. So we're all quite far over. We're going to have to go. We're at 16 .8. And - How? How are we going to achieve this high end product? Well, something has to go to the tune of 2 .3 Euro. So, let me see. What do we - 4 .3? 4 .3. Oh, yes. Sorry. 4 .3. Oh, look at the ticket ones. We're making
it a single car. Just fill in those bits. And then we're much with that save. How much so that
save? That only save you one. One. The other thing could be that you could take away the LCD panel and advance trip together. Because when you do something on the TV, the TV responds and reacts as well. So the user could be looking at the TV and pushing this thing so that we may not need to - So when we scroll, we need to some way to get the TV to respond. Okay. So - But I
think it's a technically doable thing. So - So what's our review suggestion? And take away the LCD display. Yep. And the advance trip goes away as well. To be replaced with a - Regular trip. Regular trip. Okay. So what that means is that - And so we've got .3 to get rid of. And we have - Where are the four - The four push buttons are where exactly now? The 12 buttons that you see there. 12
buttons. That's - One piece of rubber, but it's going to have 12 buttons. Functionally you have to intercept so
four is a good estimate for - Do you think? Yeah. You can't actually cut - It's like three times
the number of buttons. Okay. It's 4 -8 -12. Is that one big button or is it 12 buttons? How
can it be something in between? It needs to be more than one big button because if you open up your phone and then there's actually one button underneath, it's just that the panel itself is a single panel. Okay. Well, we have .3 to get rid of somewhere. Just reported that it has to be over budget. Or the colors - No, take away colors for the buttons. Here we could just go with normal color buttons. Well, do you want color differentiation here? No, that's not the button with our buttons. Oh, sorry, I didn't. The buttons only
refer to the pad, so - Right. So - Take that off. Aww. It's back to the original. So then
these just become normal color buttons. So that might be some way of cutting the cost. Okay. Oh, that's a
issue. Um, right? So take away that completely. Aww. And now we're under budget. So we do have .5 euro
to play with if we wanted. How about with embossing the logo? Isn't that going to cost us some money? Doesn't say so. How can that bring your colors to a special form for the buttons? Yeah, that's a good
idea. Just one? Does that mean that one button has a special form? Or - I think one button. There's just one button. Yeah. Okay. Well, there we go. So I'm just going to have to redraw this nice. We're not going to have the LCD anymore. We're just going to have an on -on the TV. We'll show you what you're doing. But I think it's fair enough. And so this is going to be one big thing. Um,
was the goal in your prototype design that it be as low profile as possible? I mean, like profile. Sort
of flat as possible. Yeah, but you're being quite deep. Yeah, deep enough to become a bit there holding your
hand. Yeah, I was being white and black. We didn't have enough play to make it. Yeah, alright. Okay, just. So there's one more dimension to the thing which we need to add. And you might want to add in
a pot length width and height. Right. Okay. So just to, well, to be thorough then, width wise, we're looking at about what three centimeters are something. Yeah. Okay. And then so height wise. High, high -talled in Visage being.
I like that. I like two centimeters. Okay. Two is not very high at all though. This is high up.
This is about two. Slightly more. Yeah. I'm by that thing. Okay. Okay. Okay. We'll say 2 .5. Okay. Um, so we have it within course anyway. Um, so yeah, project evaluation is this point. Um, right. Um, okay. So can we close that? This is what the final spec is going to be. So I'm just going to have
to. Yeah, that's fine. It's probably just, I don't know if it's worth getting into. But, um, just in, and that we want this to be stylish, should we think a little bit more out of the box in terms of a button grid? Because I've seen there's lots of devices out there that, instead of taking your standard nine, nine square grid, and they have it sort of stylized or in different concept that. I think that's something that's
very hard to catch. Yeah. So you restrict them and then look at people and try something. Sure. Okay. The look and the color is something which is cool. Yeah. I think there's also that factor of, if it's too unfamiliar. Okay. Yeah. Um, because when you put on the shape, square buttons, yeah, a bunch shape might be a good idea to change. Okay. Rather than, rather than positioning, because I think positioning is, sure, we're kind of, green,
and the telephone kind of. Okay. Right. Um, so at this point, we, uh, discuss how satisfied we all are with, um, with these four points with the ring for creativity and the project and leadership and teamwork and the stuff we have around us. I guess. Um, do you want me to, um, um, do you want me to
do my, um, design evaluation last? Now we're really sure what that was. Yeah. Evaluation. You go for that first.
I wasn't tired of sure what, uh, he was with 3D, not, but you go for it. Um, all right.
So the way this works, I'm going to need to plug into PowerPoint. Okay. I'll try and do this quick as possible. Um, I'll just go over your head if that's okay. I don't think you need the power. So,
was that? No, it's okay. I don't need the PowerPoint. No, the power cord itself. Oh, of course. So, yeah.
I didn't want freedom. okay. Okay. You should have a bit of a search. What this is is a sub for us to, um, use kind of like a, uh, idea that I've set up. I've reviewed all of the, um, the points of discussion from the beginning and use that as a criteria of evaluation for the, um, uh, for the current design, uh, or the plan. And, uh, so we can review that. I think it's going to end up being for elementary because we're not going to probably use it to change anything, but, yeah, okay, great. Uh, and I'm going to write up our results on the board. So this will be a way for us to go through and decide if we're, um, to review where we stand. Okay. So, um, so sort of bringing together two things, or design goals and also the market research that we had. Um, when we write this one is high in succeeding or fitting to our original aim and seven is low. Okay. So these, these are the, and then we've been asked to, uh, to collectively write this so we can do is trying to just work on a consensus system. So we just come to an agreement. Okay. Okay. So the first one, uh, stylish look
and feel. I read that pretty highly. Well, yeah, I mean compared to most of it controls, you see, that's pretty good. I don't know, like, six or something. Yeah. What was anybody else's? Yeah, my only reservation was that
we basically went with yellow because it's a company's color. And I don't know if yellow is going to really be a hit. But. Okay. I'm going to apply that. What do you guys think? I would say five or
six. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Non -time. Okay. Five. Okay. Oh, it's one to seven. Oh, yes. Sorry, then, then I would say two three. Okay. Wait, what's the scale? One to seven. One five. One is high. I guess, yeah,
two or three. Okay. Okay. Five. Okay. Um, control. High tech innovation. Well, possibly we jogged out of it. Yeah. So we had to remove a few of our features we wanted, but jogged out. I'd say it's more three
or four maybe. Yeah, but going towards a little bit higher than three. Okay. Okay. Um, star reflects a fruit
inspired color design. I said color. Okay. The blue colors and don't actually represent the color. Except for the red
one. They give us for one of a. But the yellow, I mean, it could be a yellow color. Yeah.
The yellow is more representative of the color, but the button itself, the blue can be anything else. Okay. So
two. Okay. And um, design is simple to use, simple and features. Yeah. And it's really basic. I think is that. I mean, I'd give that nearly a one. You guys think? Yeah. One. Yeah. Yeah, one. That's fine. Um, soft and spongy. We achieve that. We've used mostly plastic in the end. It's going to be quite a bit
of a compromise for price. Bye. That's really good. Well, that's used as plastic. Yeah. Yeah. Could we use an
entirely rubber frame? Is that an option? Yeah. I think it would be cost -possed. It would cost more than plastic. Yeah. And logo, we got it in there, haven't we? Yeah. Yeah. Gonna have that in the side. I don't know what that is. And um, it's within budget. Yeah. It is, isn't it? Yeah. Okay. So we can say then, uh, out of a possible, or, what do you have? About a 49. Yeah, 49 with, with zero being highest. Yeah. Yeah. 0 .17. 10 .15 .5. Prices. Pretty good. Translate to something like about approximately 72 % efficacy of our original goal. Right? Uh, I think, because if you turn that into a hundred, it would be about twice that. About 31. About 31. And then invert that. So, yeah. Well, you have a 69 .17. Oh, right, about 7. It's pretty good. Okay. That was just a little formality for us to go through. Okay. Oh, 100 pound pen. Sorry. New. New. So, that's honestly. The cameras did. Is that your finish? Yeah. That's, that's me. I did have one other, um, one other frame I thought, I mean, I, I'm not knowing how we would deal with this information. I thought, okay. In theory, this kind of process would be, but refining our design, revisiting our original goals. It's not something I need to push through, but I thought, should we thinking more about the dimensions? Sort of like more of a three -dimensional shapes as well as opposed to just that. Slat. Could our design involve a series of colors that it's more of like a line where we have like sort of the, yeah, I don't know like the harvest line or the vibrant. I don't know. Whatever. Just some theme and then we have different tones, line, green. Okay. It's just discussion. I mean, obviously, we can just abandon this is fine.
Just thinking about what we originally said to do. Right. Yeah. Okay. Great. Are you submitting the evaluation criteria? Or
am I, I don't know what your instructions are being made? I think they've recorded it. And I haven't been
asked to submit it yet. Okay. Just wondering if I need to include it in the minutes because if you're submitting it anyway. I will, yeah. Okay. Thank you. Right. Well, next up then because we've done finance is the
project evaluation. Yeah, I'm just trying to incorporate the logo into the thing. So I'm playing with the play though
as well. Just in case you're wondering. You're still playing with the play though. Right. Okay. Well, do you want to just individually say what you think about these four points and what you're going to do? I don't know. I've got a different... I like those printer cables that just have the two little butterfly clips. Right. Okay. Yeah, here we are. I don't know what we'll do this alphabetically. And to the start. Sure. So what is it you're asking of me now? I don't know. And your opinion on those four points really and how are we...
Sort of our work on setting this up. Yeah. Well, okay. I'll just go through your system. And the room is pretty institutional. But the main thing is, I think, our use of this space is more just to report on things as opposed to be creative and constructive and would probably help to have sort of a cumulative effect of we have ideas and we come back and then the ideas are still in discussion. In other words, this room is sort of a center point of creativity. Whereas in reality as we've gone through this, it's not really
a center point of creativity. It's more just to... Do you feel though that you were able to have quite
a lot of creative input into this? Yeah, yeah. But that's just the thing is the question in terms of the first point there, the room. The field of the creativity goes on when we leave and then we come here and then we kind of put out our ideas. I don't think it means the room as in this room. I think it means that... Oh, right, right, all right. Yeah. All right, I just looked up and saw,
okay, wait for digital pens, the room. No, of course, yeah. Well, I do know. I think it means... I
think it means did you think you were able to give creative input? Yeah, okay, yeah, answering the question in those terms. I'd say that actually there's sort of a tease of creativity because we're asked to work through this, but actually the guideline, they're fairly contrived in terms of... Okay, fashion trends, they're for in vegetable color scheme, but then we're told to use the company colors. So what do we do? We're told to think in terms of style and looking for your own technology, but build something for 12 and a half pounds. Okay. So actually the creativity is more of like a sort of a formality than... I feel like caged within... Yeah, whatever... Like a
balloon in a cage, you can go so big if not hit the side, the constraints do come in. Yeah,
actually let's take each point and everybody discuss that, I think. So still on the topic of room for creativity.
Next up is Crate. I agree with his points. It's quite a lot of fun to go through and then you have to start at the end and go right, go out and play out, because we don't have enough
money. Yeah. Yeah. Another point is that the meetings are more brainstorming sessions than meetings. So time is also a very strong factor in structure, because for brainstorming meeting you want a structure that allows you to... allows ideas to get tossed, to be evaluated, and to be reviewed, and to get feedback and come back. And I guess that point about the room not being very friendly to that, I think that's a very big thing. And I think the fact that we're wearing these things restricts... I feel it, because I wear my glasses right, but that irritates me right. It does actually affect whether you feel comfortable to communicate. I feel like I'm hiding behind the equipment, rather than the equipment is helping me. So you think I'm wearing a relaxed atmosphere, it would be more kind of... Not so much an atmosphere, an atmosphere is very relaxed, but the atmosphere creates boundaries to that. And the
time given also restricts. Very good. What about leadership? I don't know if I think I could give it to...
Yeah, well... I mean, my sense on that is sort of what kind of guidance and direction and encouragement. So
I'm like your personal coach, personal stuff like that. Yeah, from you as well. I think I can do a
team leader. Okay. Yeah, I think it's good. I mean, my personal views on leadership is that effective leadership sort of gives people a certain room for freedom and delegation, but then come back to something that they take great ownership and innovative thought with. In reality, I think here the different elements of leadership, such as the original briefing and then the personal coach and then having you with the meeting agenda is actually quite a... And so it is leadership, also the point of sort of disempowering the team member. Okay. But it's not a bad leadership, it's just sort of fairly strong. It turns the individual into more of like a sort of predetermined mechanism as opposed
to... So you think maybe I'm too controlling or... Yeah, I think controlling is not the right word. The interaction
is very structured. I think structure is probably what you're saying that each individual is structured to one particular task and one, rather than controlling. I don't mean as a sense of control because our decisions have been made in terms of a consensus, right? We go around and we think about it, but that process actually says you have to do it in a certain way. It doesn't tell you, you know, sometimes you might want to be a bit more creative in terms of the process. Yeah, not the... Okay. What about teamwork? Does it work? That was
a bit hard because we could only discuss things in the meeting. If we could just go up to somebody outside the meeting and have a quick talk with them, I would have been out of all the easier. Okay.
I think you tried to use the common share folder to communicate, but it just comes back to us so slow in the email. It doesn't have a messenger. Did you guys get the email I sent you? Yeah, I
was wondering if that got there. Okay. So to summarize the teamwork issue, saying that if we could communicate outside the meeting, you know, just quick questions, quick thoughts, whatever, it probably would be... I think the tools that they
were given, the tools that they were given to us are fancy, but they don't support collaboration. I think that's what they don't support the team working together. Yeah. I mean, they're still very individual tools. Yeah. I mean, sort
of taking upon that idea, the way I see this is that it's the structure in which we've approached this whole task is quite contrary to the principle of teamwork, because the tasks were divided. And then the work went on in isolation. I don't know what you guys did while you were together. Maybe that was a bit different. But actually, if you imagine not entirely completely same task given to us, but us said, okay, first thing we have to do is come up with a design concept. And we sit here together and do it. Well, that's what teamwork is to say, okay, go off and don't talk to each other. Yeah. It actually sort of predisposes you to quite the contrary of teamwork. Okay. Not that we haven't done, I think, the best we could have
done. Okay. Not dissatisfied with it. Right. Anything else to say on the teamwork tool? No. Okay. What about the, you know, how we use the whiteboard, the digital pens, the projector, stuff like that? Did anybody think anything was
that really useful? Anything was pretty unsupported? I think the whiteboard, for me, is the kind of thing I would use all the time. But it's not quite as useful to us as it could have been, maybe just in the way that we use it in the sense that once we have an idea out there, or while work was going on in between meetings, that could have been up on a board, you know, the post to, in, like, in text. And then we could then keep our ideas sort of building on that. I know that people who design cars and, you know, an aviation, they quite often just have a simple, like, fiberglass prototype. And it's completely, you know, abstract from the final product, but they use it as a kind of a context to sort of walk around and puzzle and point that point and discuss. And in a way, everybody's, as we discuss things in theoretically and out of our notebooks, we're just, we're actually just, each of us discussing something in each of our own minds. It wasn't until we had this here, you know, like at one point I peeked across and looked at Craig's paper and I'm like, now I know what he's thinking, because I saw his book. But the whiteboard could have actually been this kind of continuing. So do you think producing a prototype earlier in the process
would have been a good idea? I think the focus of it a lot was the PowerPoint as opposed to the whiteboard. And I think that that is also does. Yeah. In those things, I think it will be cooler to have the whiteboard rather than the PowerPoint or maybe the whiteboard and the PowerPoint in the same place. Yeah,
because the PowerPoint was provided to us while we had time to prepare, whereas I can imagine if I've been encouraged to use paintbrush, for example, or whatever, I would have actually used it. Yeah, just because that's sort of how we set up to you. We have that time. Thank you. I think there are too many PowerPoints and
the plugins spent on the time doing that. And a lot of information on the PowerPoints. I don't think you need it to actually, we could have gone through it very verbally, especially my slides I felt that. Okay. You
know, as opposed to having to present them. What about the digital pens? Did you find them easy enough to
use? I'm not sure. Yeah, kanki. Agreed. Kanki. Okay. Having to take it before you go off was a bit hindering as well, because you have to go through a thought and then you run out of paper and then
you have to jump. I know I think at the very start of today, I, like, who did a stuff, didn't click note on one, then went back and wrote one tiny thing on the another page, but then they clicked note. So I'm quite worried that I've just written over the top of it or something, but they'll have
my paper anyway. I think the pen is very intuitive. Everybody knows how to use it. You don't have to worry. Yeah. I think the pen is good. It's about the best thing. On the topic of the technology, it
just occurred to me that we actually didn't need to move our computers because each computer has all of the files. Yeah. It just occurred to me that we only need one computer. We only actually need one computer. Yeah. If there had been a fifth, it could have just been sitting there ready to go to the whole computer.
And the computer may not be conducive to a meeting because you tend to look at your computer and want to have the urge to check something. It's useful, but. Do you think the computers just provide distraction in the meeting? I think too many computers are just distracting. Okay. And I like to have things written down in front
of me, actually. Like, a lot of the stuff that was emailed to me, I ended up writing down there or something. So I could look at it really quickly and not have the distraction of all of that. I don't know why anybody else. What else? Any, I'm not really sure what they're looking for in the same new ideas find. I don't know, as you can think of that, anything else that would have been helpful today. That's
all. Well, the main one for me is that the process and a natural context would not have been interrupted by this necessity to discommunicate ourselves. That's kind of a new idea for me is just sort of that idea. It's kind of hard to keep working forward on a team -based project when you're told you must now work
away from each other. Yeah. I think it was quite good that we had time limits on the meetings because they really could have run on. My experience with meetings is that they really do. You can spend a lot of time talking about it. The only thing is when we had our meeting about the conceptual design, I thought there maybe another 15 minutes would have been useful there. I think maybe if we all have been working in the one room and they just said every hour or something, everybody make sure you just have a short meeting and then just to have something written down. Just like a milestone, if you like, my mother's in having meetings. There you go. So, it's not my 5 minutes to go. Oh, there it is. Five minutes to go. Okay, are the courses in the budget? Yes, they are. Is the project evaluated? Yes, it is. It's a nice, elaborate. So we have Ninja, Homer. Well, apparently I write the final report. What are you guys doing, though? I don't
know. Oh, wow. That is lovely. Yeah, I said Ninja, Homer. What did you call it? Ninja, Homer. See, it looks like Homer Simpson. So it's me that I am. Is that the stilago or is it doing a thing?
Yes, it's just a logo. Just a logo and then like Ninja, Homer, right? The red is supposed to represent
whatever else you want to print on the side of it. It's crashing technology or something. You can wear Homer.
You can throw Homer when you're frustrated. That is cool. I'm slightly gutted that we can get plastic and rubber. I think that would have been nice. Oh, well. Maybe for now, I'm real reaction. Should give us more money.
Oh, I did learn something. Play -Doh is useful. No, it is. It is useful in conceptualizing, in being creative. It's like you say it's something you can put your hands on and feel and touch. Yeah, the sense where we were playing with the play -Doh and the ideas came with the play -Doh. Did it. Rather than with everything else, you might want to write that. I'm just fling with the play -Doh. Yeah, it's not true. Play
-Doh. So I think it's the play -Doh smells. Yeah, it smells funny, doesn't it? It's like, the play -Doh
is actually edible, isn't it? Yeah, let's stuff it. I think it has to be a... It's just wheat. It's
the stuff that your mom could make with preservatives in there. So what are your summarizing words about play -Doh?
It's helpful to the creative process. It engages all your senses, not just your sight, but your sense of fuel, your sense of touch. It helps you to understand. I mentioned as well. I think that's very helpful because it's such to pop up. Whereas on a piece of paper, on a computer, on a board, even with a treaty graphic thing, it still requires a lot of time to be tangible. Yeah, tangible, that's a nice word. It becomes
tangible. Tangible. Okay. I don't know if there's anything else. Nope. Any chair? Discuss? That's about it, really. Does it
still, I guess, evermore? Do we retreat to our... To continue our... I think we could probably do it here.
What do we do? Well, I do know. I'm sure that the thing will pop up any minute now. Can you turn off the microphones? Yeah, yeah. The meeting's over, then yeah. And my microphone has no signal. Which would
explain why you don't get any signal. My love either. Yeah, it might be because of the power, though. I
wish, one bug. I think the time has to run out first to get any more instructions. Yeah. Doesn't it? Is it good? Yeah. Okay. That's pretty cool. I can see the... The talk. I can see my own voice on there. You really want to? You You You You You